vous interroger le chef des minoritaires
de la fronde socialiste minoritaire
exige lui mais bien sûr qu'ils existent
mais ils sont minoritaires il ya eu un
congrès ils ont été battus et une large
majorité a choisi une orientation
politique c'est comme lorsque l'on vote
dans les groupes parlementaires mais ils
disent mais c'est verrouillé mais moi je
leur dis que par leurs interventions on
risque de prendre une dérouillée aux
élections régionales le problème c'est
pas que ce soit verrouillé c'est pas
verrouillé le débat raider faute mais
non mais faut qu'ils arrêtent de passer
leur temps de critiquer et de critiquer
sans cesse la politique du gouvernement